don't have your hand out here
my body is displacing very tight
uh like this okay
here boom my elbow is gonna turn and
i'll have this straight
now don't bring your hand outside elbow
turn
bring
[Music]
very tight
okay there's no there's no power when
you unanchor your elbow
you're much tighter
not out you see and then you lean
no i'm really tired
so he's doing that and having a shield
this shield
okay let's try i'm not gonna compromise
my posture go here
i'm here in
anything i touch i can't i can't project
so
i'm going to try to touch his center
right at contact
i'm not going like this i'm not bracing
for impact
i just touch piss
just to touch it touch it you see
you see how i'm doing that i'm just
exaggerating the knock down
i just want to touch his center it
touches me oh my
god you see okay
he goes warm and i pass down
[Music]
i first have contact but i don't
project i yield it
won't yield
oh
and you
you
tight tight tight get tighter
tighter you see our range tight
that's it
make sure you're ready you'll start
going on your crazy ass range
okay in the end but i yield
boom grab the head
come on push
let's go
okay let's go i don't have to kill him
to make the point
so if he's pausing it's because he's
getting pinned
do you see that and he's waiting for the
pressure to stop
well if that that means that that move
could have
affected his center so you do that you
do the strike
i'm not going here that was an
emphasis do you see did you feel your
knees come up
to distinguish i'm not doing this do you
see the difference
so i go this is a drill do you see
but the technique is here
keeps going did you stop striking
okay
so we'll again go back to a drill mode
in tighter he's going to do that same
movement
but i'm gonna stick to him he goes when
i feel that pressure
don't miss when i feel that pressure
we'll have him do his roll first okay
yep
hit the elbow in the hand will come out
there you go i'll do it okay
inside
okay let's go look he's doing he's doing
that
okay he goes i'm in here and
i'm gonna do the heel right there find
the head
boom
we're starting tight i'll feel his
energy go but i'm already
using all the center okay but i'm gonna
yield
boom find the head
tight he goes no
it's a yielding practice
he's just gonna i'm gonna feel the yin
when the elbow goes watch
boom you see but i
go
yes
[Music]
okay look your your internal skills go
right so my my internal skills won't
is can be supplemented by my external
movements
if you're getting compromised because
you can't you can't go ahead
you can't absorb here then move
but this is not ever going to be right
do you see this disappear
boom okay
it's a disappearing drill let's go
do the strike without filming do you
think
i'm not going to be able to cut here
but what i can do he goes it passes
and pull that do you see and then give
him something to hold on to because he
will
and then i control him
so we're here he goes that's my turn
then i find the arm at the bottom when
he's reaching for
something to break something or you can
think of it as
he goes and it's your strike
you see
not here don't start arm fighting
find the arm at the bottom keep contact
with it
but you're not that's not what's taking
this balance okay
don't move it out a little bit i don't
have contact
okay but you're gonna feel you're gonna
have the same hand sensation so he goes
you see
it's no different than he does show
manucci and you follow it up
he does yoko medicine you follow he goes
boom and he goes
engage
connect seek connection
he goes i'm in i should be it he goes
[Music]
it's not advantageous for me to close
the gap the advantage
is over here okay
so there's got to be a reason why i make
contact with his stripe
and it's not that i'm waiting for it to
get to me
okay so don't start it from way out
there
all i asked you to do was don't start at
contact already
so i'm in here he's gonna i'm gonna be
okay
i'm in here so that he knows he's gonna
if he
takes his step back he might have missed
that one but he's gonna get that one so
he's gonna
see the advantages closing the gap not
trying to
build the cap it's too late okay
so we're in here but we're not here
can you see that difference okay so he
goes
and i'm here
i have to have the reason he goes
i feel in my heel
i'm not doing this
[Music]
i have to absorb it whoa stick
find the new opening watch how i change
my levels
most of you aren't even changing your
level you're up here
drive your way drop your weight boom
okay try it again it is a lot to ask
to be on the outside of the circular
strike
because he's coming from the flank
somehow they outflanked his plane
these techniques are how to get to the
outside from the inside
okay so when when he goes
i'm on the inside do you see me
not out here i'm on the inside
i do the yield
it's not i'm not here this is already
lowering him
here here
picks up body moves
i'm not trying to get to the outside
i'm on the inside
on the inside
so let's slow it back down
oh
not here when i go here
i'm here and i yield here
this is our unchecked please check
you can see that same
donor sanctuary you're always in
you're always in to the back
it's not that i move around him and get
to the back corner
is that he moves around me gets there
nearly impossible back up to the strike
you get back here
but so you know what why not
not do it why don't we move the corner
to where i
have it in front of me instead of me
getting to the back of him
he gets to the front of me okay so he
goes
oh there it is i'm there
i'm in the exact spot
oh
here i got it i'm already there i'm
already there
already
okay just that drill at least get your
head
behind that corner go okay so this
this the strategy is the strategy of
jiu-jitsu
yield okay but you need the
internal aspects too so if i go here
and will you mind leaning on me get your
feet out
so you can lean you see i'm actually
stopping in the entire time
stopping okay that's not right
but getting out of the way isn't it
either because he has his balance
so when i do when i yield it i have to
generate
i can't go negative but i can't be
positive
i got half the class negative and half
the class positive
it has to be neutral okay so
i'm always riding that neutral so that i
can get those
adhesions which is aikido
so yes strategy is yield but yeah you're
yielding but you're positive
or you're yielding and you're negative
he has to
he has to move in front of me okay
if i leave him out there of course he's
never going to get in front of me
but if i leave him there he's not going
to get in front of me and i have to be
the one to move
so i yield so that i stick
i keep moving him keep moving him
stick there's balance but that's
stopping bring it this way
there okay got it
okay try it again so that girl please
move over here
that drill was just an exaggeration
right it's just
exact so i'm not i'm not stopping do you
feel that okay i'm yielding but i'm
stopping him okay
this is yielding but i'm not pulling him
i'm not adhering to him
so same thing here so like yeah you can
go like that
don't in this drill i'm gonna i'm gonna
actually move him
move him
we're going to step up to the next row
so all i want here
is the same yield he goes won't that was
it
technique done this hand now finishes it
[Music]
boom that was it right here this hand
there
[Music]
some of you don't do that and so it's
very hard to get that
only stand straight up here
i keep hold that was it that little step
that's where i keep going
not stop grab
[Music]
stop don't do the throw yet i just want
the kazushi on the head
yield pull okay he goes
here you that was it
[Music]
your moves are small and they're
incremental
so he goes pull a heel
and then i'll find his center again with
whatever i'm touching
okay with whatever i'm touching
you'll find his center i don't know if
it'll be the arm or the hip
um but i like to go for the arm because
he'll reach out for me
so i want to check the arm okay meaning
i don't want to come he goes and then
i'm over here on the outside and i get
taken down
so i like to clear the arm
pull i'm here stop being the grab you
see that
and so when i find the grab i create
another adhesion here
and then i use it to project
whether i grab it or not it still
projections
okay so he goes heals
but it's like three stages so engage
yield head
and boom project okay let's try it again